à tous ces vélos c'est simplement donc
la grande masse du vélo à la réunion
sorefi réunion cyclo tour qui donne
mille 300 vélos et plus 1500 quasiment
avec bâle et les aléas qui sont là et
puis surtout des gens très content
d'être blesse d'être présent pour à
l'épée d'aller faire la fête taurine
moi c'est ma vie j'ai toujours fait du
vélo depuis l'âge de 6 mois donc
c'est un plaisir et c'est le plaisir
partagé une journée de faire la fête
c'est une belle fête aujourd'hui nous
allons la matière mais les écolos c'est
un défilé on dirait voir le beau on
dirait way défilé de mode c'est vrai
défilé de mode et ouais c'est le gars
d'échiquier pas pédaler l'or ne vaut
rien l'entraîneur chilien bienvenus
c'était quoi l'entraînement mais grâce
aux six gagnants
et
ces jeux
c'est ma vie où j'avais le plus c'est
mieux
l'image est bonne c'est lent
super manifestation a mis son veto même
pas peur enfin pour l'instant
c'est après bientôt effectivement c'est
bien c'est bien ça c'est super
à la cool
jadis micro la de l'amateur acharné
baladeur avec un certain plaisir
et
m
tu profites de la vie ou gore problème
c'est ça le gros trou de vent j'ai les
prix et boum
il ya plusieurs la belle a maintenant
réparation on va reparler de ce
lotissement la route
elle est encore longue le cycliste est
philosophe ouais exactement
voilà quand on n'a pas le choix
e
répéter que la route se partage que la
route se partage et que soyons ans clara
utilisez-les utiliser le vélo à chaque
fois que c'est possible pour les
déplacements inférieurs à 500 km à et
puis bien entendu il ya aussi le goût tv
le loisir que chacun peut utiliser
acheter des vivres
courage équipe on arrive oui avec son
groupe d'amis de la ligue 1 samedi
d'accord c'est important de piano
vouloir se dit quoi vous leur devez
d'énergie l'aîné 6 le ravitaillement
ouais et puis bon courage à lui allez
vive le des lobbys le spo
de dix commandements du dit si tu me
trouve plus aujourd'hui c'est pas grave
je suis parti avec le premier il a
intérêt à se dépêcher alors
ça va le motiver un petit peu là pour la
journée
revenu à ses parts ou
tu fais plaisir nous mais quand même
façon à terme ça au rugby et de la vanne
franchement été vraiment qu'aux j'étais
mérite notre place pour partager un peu
le vélo est ferme et un peu tout le
monde dans l'esprit de compétition un
petit peu
bah c'est ce qu'il faut ce qu'il faut
pour motiver un petit peu les anciens
les seniors emplois par mois
c'est important de vivre l'épreuve fouet
puis c'est pour tous les niveaux il ya
les meilleurs qui sont vraiment de bons
pour la course
et puis et puis après ceux qui essaient
de tenir derrière donc c'est non c'est
odieux on n'avait pas trop les jambes
donc on a sauté et là on a récupéré le
groupe plus loin savez qu'il ya des gens
qui savent pas ce que ça veut dire
on a sauté personne n'a juste sorti du
peloton n'a décroché et on ne rendra
vraiment on a sauté personnes
c'est le principe de la cyclo c'est pour
les meilleurs c'est pour les moyens et
puis pour les débutants donc c'est c'est
l'esprit vélo